The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Welcome
to Foundations
of Computational
and Systems Biology.
This course has many numbers.
We'll explain all the
differences and similarities.
But briefly, there are three
undergrad course numbers,
which are all similar in
content, 7.36, 20.390, 6.802.
And then, there are
four graduate versions.
The 7.91, 20.490, and HST
versions are all very similar,
basically identical.
But the 6.874 has some
additional AI content
that we'll discuss in a moment.
So make sure that
you are registered
for the appropriate
version of this course.
And please interrupt with
questions at any time.
The main goal today is to give
an overview of the course, both
the content as well as
the mechanics of how
the course will be taught.
And we want to make sure
that everything is clear.
So this course is
taught by myself
and Chris Burge from Biology,
Professor Fraenkel from BE,
and Professor Gifford from EECS.
We have three TAs, Peter
Freese and Collette Picard,
from Computational and Systems
Biology, and Tahin, from EECS.
All the TAs have expertise
in computational biology
as well as other
quantitative areas
like math, statistics,
computer science.
So in addition to the lectures
by the regular instructors,
we will also have guest
lectures by George Church,
from Harvard, toward
the end of the semester.
Doug Lauffenburger
will give a lecture
in the regulatory network
section of the course.
And we'll have a guest
lecture from Ron Weiss
on synthetic biology.
And just a note
that today's lecture
and all the lectures
this semester
are being recorded by AMPS,
by MIT's OpenCourseWare.
So the videos, after a
little bit of editing,
will eventually end
up on OpenCourseWare.
What are these courses?
So these course numbers are
the graduate level versions,
which are survey courses
in computational biology.
Our target audience
is graduate students
who have a solid
background and comfort--
or, a solid
background in biology,
and also, a comfort with
quantitative approaches.
We don't assume that
you've programmed before,
but there will be
some programming
content on the homeworks.
And you will therefore need to
learn some Python programming.
And the TAs will help with
that component of the course.
We also have some online
tutorials on Python programming
that are available.
The undergrad course
numbers-- this
is an upper level
undergraduate survey
course in computational biology.
And our target audience are
upper level undergraduates
with solid biology
background and comfort
with quantitative approaches.
So there's one key difference
between the graduate
and undergraduate versions,
which I'll come to in a moment.
So the goal of this course
is to develop understanding
of foundational methods in
computational biology that
will enable you to
contextualize and understand
a good portion of research
literature in a growing field.
So if you pick up Science, or
Nature, or PLOS Computational
Biology and you want
to read those papers
and understand them,
after this course,
you will have a better chance.
We're not guaranteeing you'll be
able to understand all of them.
But you'll be able to recognize,
perhaps, the category of paper,
the class, and perhaps,
some of the algorithms
that are involved.
And for the graduate
version, another goal
is to help you gain exposure
to research in this field.
So it's actually
possible to do a smaller
scale computational biology
research project on your own,
on your laptop-- perhaps,
on ATHENA-- with relatively
limited computational
resources and potentially
even discover something new.
And so we want to give
you that experience.
And that's through
the project component
that we'll say more
about in a moment.
So just to make sure that
everyone's in the right class--
this is not a systems
biology class.
There are some more
focused systems
biology classes
offered on campus.
But we will cover
some topics that
are important for
analyzing complex systems.
This is also certainly not
a synthetic biology course.
Some of the systems methods are
also used in synthetic biology.
And there will be this
guest lecturer I mentioned,
Ron Weiss, which will
cover synthetic biology.
It's also not an
algorithms class.
We don't assume that
you have experience
in designing or
analyzing algorithms.
We'll discuss various
bioinformatics algorithms.
And you'll have the
opportunity to implement
at least one bioinformatics
algorithm on your homework.
But algorithms and not really
the center of the course.
And there's one
exception to this,
which is, those of you
who are taking 6.874
will go to a special
recitation that
will cover more advanced
algorithm content.
And there will be special
homework problems for you
as well.
So that course really does
have more algorithm content.
So the plan for today
is that I will just
do a brief, anecdotal history
of computational and systems
biology.
This is to set the stage and
the context for the class.
And then we'll spend
a significant amount
of time reviewing the course
mechanics, organization,
and content.
Because as you'll see, it's
a little bit complicated.
But it'll make sense once
we go over it, hopefully.
So this is my take
on computational
and systems biology.
Again, it's not a
scholarly overview.
It doesn't hit everything
important that happened.
It just gives you
a flavor of what
was happening in computational
biology decade by decade.
So first of all,
where does this field
fall in the academic
scheme of things?
So I consider
computational biology
to be actually part of biology.
So in the way that genetics or
biochemistry are disciplines
that have strategies
for understanding
biological questions, so
does computational biology.
You can use it to
understand a variety
of computational
questions in gene
regulation, many other areas.
There is also, some
people make a distinction
that bioinformatics is
more about building tools
whereas computational biology
is more about using tools,
for example.
Although many people
don't-- it's very blurry--
and don't try to-- people
use them in various ways.
And then, you could
think of bioinformatics
as being embedded in the larger
field of informatics, where you
include tools for management
and analysis of data in general.
And it's certainly true that
many of the core concepts
and algorithms in bioinformatics
come from the field,
come from computer science,
come from other branches
of engineering, from statistics,
mathematics, and so forth.
So it's really a cross
disciplinary field.
And then, synthetic biology
cuts across in the sense
that it's really an
engineering discipline.
Because you're designing
and engineering
synthetic molecular
cellular systems.
But you can also use
synthetic biology
to help understand natural
biological systems, of course.
All right, so what was
happening, decade by decade?
So in the '70s, there
were not genome sequences
available or large sequence
databases of any sort.
Except there were starting
to be some protein sequences.
And early computational
biologists
focused on comparing proteins,
understanding their function,
structure, and evolution.
And so in order to
compare proteins,
you need a protein-- an amino
acid substitution matrix--
a matrix that describes
how often one amino acid is
substituted for another.
And Margaret Dayhoff
was a pioneer
in developing these
sorts of matrices.
And some of the matrices she
developed, the PAM series,
are still used today.
And we'll discuss those
matrices early next week.
So in terms of asking
evolutionary questions,
two big thinkers were Russ
Doolittle and Carl Woese,
analyzing both ribosomal RNA
sequences to study evolution.
And Carl Woese realized,
looking at these RNA alignments,
that actually, the prokaryotes,
which had been-- there
was this big split
between prokaryotes
and eukaryotes was
sort of a false split--
that actually,
there was a subgroup
of single-celled
anuclear organisms
that were closer
to the eukaryotes--
and named them the Archaea.
So a whole kingdom of life
was recognized, really,
by sequence analysis.
And Russ Doolittle also
did a lot of analysis
approaching sequences and came
up with this molecular clock
idea, or contributed
to that idea,
to actually build-- instead
of systematics being based
on phenotypic characteristics,
do it on a molecular level.
So in the '80s, the
databases started to expand.
Sequence alignment and
search became more important.
And various people
developed fast algorithms
to compare protein and DNA
sequences and align them.
So the FASTA program
was widely used.
BLAST-- several of the authors
of BLAST are shown here--
David Lipman, Pearson, Webb
Miller, Stephen Altschul.
The statistics for knowing
when a BLAST search result is
significant were developed
by Karlin and Altschul.
And there was also progress
in gapped alignment,
in particularly,
Smith-Waterman, shown above.
Also progress in RNA
secondary structure prediction
from Nusinov and Zuker.
We'll talk about all of these
algorithms during the course.
And there was also development
of literature databases.
I always liked this picture.
Many of you probably
used PubMed.
But Al Gore was well coached
here, by these experts,
in how to use it.
And then, in the '90s,
computational biology
really started to expand.
It was driven partly
by the development
of a microarrays, the first
genome sequences, and questions
like how to identify
domains in a protein,
how to identify
genes in the genome.
It was recognized that
this family of models
from electrical engineering,
the hidden Markov model,
were quite useful for these sort
of sequence labeling problems.
That was really pioneered
by Anders Krogh here,
and David Haussler.
And a variety of
algorithms were developed
that performed
these useful tasks.
There was also
important progress
in the earliest comparative
genomic approaches,
since you have--
the first genomes
were sequenced in the mid
'90s, of free living organisms.
And so you could then start
to compare these genomes
and learn a lot.
We'll talk a little bit
about comparative genomics.
And there was important progress
on predicting protein structure
from primary sequence.
Particularly, David Baker
made notable progress
on this Rosetta algorithm.
So it's a biophysics
field, but it's
very much part of
computational biology as well.
So in the 2000s, definitely,
genome sequencing
became very fashionable,
as you can see here.
And the genomes of
now larger organisms,
including human, it became
possible to sequence them.
And then, this
introduced a huge host
of computational challenges
in assembling the genomes,
annotating the
genomes, and so forth.
And we'll hear from
Professor Gifford
about some genome
assembly topics.
And annotation will
come up throughout.
Actually, let's
just mention, this
is Jim Kent, who's the guru
who did the first human genome
assembly-- at least,
that was widely used--
and also was involved in UCSC.
And here, Ewan Birney
has started Ensembl
and continues to run it today.
You know who these other
people are, probably.
OK.
All right.
So in another phase
of the last decade,
I would say that much
of biological research
became more high throughput
than it was before.
So molecular biology
had traditionally,
in the '80s and
'90s, mostly focused
on analysis of individual
gene or protein products.
But now it became possible,
and in widespread use,
that you could measure the
expression of all the genes,
in theory-- using
microarrays, for example--
and you could start
to profile all
of the transcripts
in the cell, all
of the proteins in the
cell, and so forth.
And then, a variety
of groups started
to use some of these
high throughput data
to study various challenges
in gene expression
to understand how transcription
works, how splicing works,
how microRNAs work, translation,
epigenetics, and so forth.
And you'll hear updates on some
of that work in this course.
Bioimage informatics,
particularly
for developmental
biology, became popular.
It continues to be
a new emerging area.
Systems biology was also really
born around 2000, roughly.
A very prominent example
would be the development
of the first gene
regulatory network
models that describe sea urchin
development, here, my Eric
Davidson, as well as a whole
variety of models of other gene
networks in the cell
that control things like
cell proliferation,
apoptosis, et cetera.
At the same time, a new
field of synthetic biology
was born with the development
of some of the first
completely artificial gene
networks that would then
program cells to perform
desired behavior.
So an example would be this
so-called repressilator,
where you have a network of
three transcription factors.
Each represses the other.
And then, one of
them represses GFP.
And you put these into bacteria.
And it causes oscillations
in GFP, expressions
that are described by these
differential equations here.
And some of the
modeling approaches
used in synthetic
biology will be
covered by Professor Fraenkel
and Lauffenburger later.
All right.
So late 2000s, early
2010s, it's still too early
to say, for sure, what the most
important developments will be.
But certainly, in
the late 2000s,
next gen sequencing--
which now probably
should be called second
generation sequencing,
since there may be
future generations--
really started to transform
a whole wide variety
of applications in biology,
from making genome sequencing--
instead of having to be
done in the genome center,
now an individual lab can easily
do microbial genome sequencing.
And when needed,
it's possible, also,
to do genome sequencing
of larger organisms.
Transcriptome sequencing
is now routine.
We'll hear about that.
There are applications
for mapping protein-DNA
interactions genome
wide, including
both sequence specific
transcription factors
as well as more general
factors like histones,
protein-RNA interactions--
a method called
CLIP-Seq-- methods for mapping
all the translated messages,
the methylated sites in
the genome, open chromatin,
and so forth.
So many people contributed
to this, obviously.
I'm just mentioning,
Barbara Wold
was a pioneer in both
RNA-Seq as well as ChIP-Seq.
And some of the sequencing
technologies that came out here
are shown here.
And we will discuss those
at the beginning of lecture
on Thursday.
So I encourage you to
read this review here,
by Metzger, which covers
many of the newer sequencing
technologies.
And they're pretty interesting.
As you'll see, there's
some interesting tricks,
interesting chemistry and
image analysis tricks.
All right.
So that was not very scholarly.
But if you want a proper
history, then this guy,
Hallam Stevens, who was a
History of Science PhD student
at Harvard and
recently graduated,
wrote this history
of bioinformatics.
OK.
So let's look at the syllabus.
So also posted on the
[INAUDIBLE] site is a syllabus.
It looks like this.
This is quite an
information-rich document.
It has all the lecture
titles, all the due dates
of all the problem
sets, and so forth.
So please print yourself a
copy and familiarize yourself
with it.
So we'll just try to
look at a high level
first, and then zoom
in to the details.
So at a high level, if you
look in this column here,
we've broken the course
into six different topics.
OK?
So there's Genomic
Analysis I, that I'll
be teaching, which is more
classical computational
biology, you could say-- local
alignment, global alignment,
and so forth.
Then, Genomic Analysis II,
which Professor Gifford will
be teaching, covers
some newer methods
that are required
when you're doing
a lot of second
generation sequencing--
the standard algorithms
are not fast enough,
you need better
algorithms, and so forth.
And then, I will come back and
give a few lectures on modeling
biological function.
This will have to do with
sequence motifs, hidden Markov
models, and RNA
secondary structure.
Professor Fraenkel
will then do a unit
on proteomics and
protein structure.
And then, there will
be an extended unit
on regulatory networks.
Different types of
regulatory networks
will be covered, with most
of the lectures by Ernest,
one by David, and one by Doug.
And then, we'll finish up
with computational genetics,
by David.
And there will also be some
guest lecturers, one of them
interspersed in
regulatory networks,
and then two at the end, from
Ron Weiss and George Church.
So I just wanted to point out
that in all of these topics,
we will include some discussion
of motivating question.
So, what are the
biological questions
that we're seeking to address
with these approaches.
And there will also
be some discussion
of the experimental method.
So for example,
in the first unit,
it's heavy on sequence analysis.
So we'll talk about
how sequencing is done,
and then, quite a bit
about the interaction
between the
experimental technology
and the computational
analysis, which often involves
statistical methods for
estimating the error
rate of the experimental
method, and things like that.
So the emphasis is on
the computational part,
but we'll have some
discussion about experiments.
Everyone with me so far?
Any questions?
OK.
All right.
So what are some of these
motivating questions
that we'll be talking about?
So what are the instructions
encoded in our genomes?
You can think of the
genome as a book.
But it's in this very
strange language.
And we need to understand the
rules, the code that underlies
a lot of research
in gene expression.
How are chromosomes organized?
What genes are present-- so
tools for annotating genomes.
What regulatory
circuitry is encoded?
You'd like to be able to
eventually look at a genome,
understand all the
regulatory elements,
and be able to predict
that there's some feedback
circuit there that responds to--
a particular stimulation that
responds to light, or
nutrient deprivation,
or whatever it might be.
Can the transcriptome be
predicted from the genome?
This is a longstanding question.
The translatome, if you
will-- well, let's say,
the proteome can be predicted
from the transcriptome
in the sense that we
have a genetic code
and we can look
up those triplets.
So there's a dream
that we would be
able to model other
steps in gene expression
with the precision with which
the genetic code predicts
translation-- that we'd
be able to predict where
the polymerase would start
transcribing, where it will
finish transcribing, how a
transcript will be spliced,
et cetera-- all the other
steps in gene expression.
And that motivates a lot
of work in the field.
Can protein function be
predicted from sequence?
So this is a very
classical problem.
But there are a number of new
and interesting developments
as resolved from a lot of
this high throughput data
generation, both in
nucleic acid sequencing
as well as in proteomics.
Can evolutionary history be
reconstructed from sequence?
Again, this has been a
longstanding goal of the field.
And a lot of progress
has been made here.
And now most evolutionary
classifications
are actually based on molecular
sequence at some level.
And new species are often
defined based on sequence.
OK.
Other motivating questions.
So what would you
need to measure
if you wanted to discover
the causes of a disease,
the mechanisms of
existing drugs,
metabolic pathways
in a micro-organism?
So this is a systems
biology question.
You've got a new bug.
It causes some disease.
What should you measure?
Should you sequences its genome?
Should you sequence
its transcriptome?
Should you do proteomics?
What type of proteomics?
Should you perturb the system in
some way and do a time series?
What are the most
efficient ways?
What information should
be gathered, and in what
quantities?
And how should that information
be integrated in order
to come up with an
understanding of the physiology
of that organisms
so that, then, you
can know where to
intervene, what
would be suitable drug targets?
Yeah.
What kind of modeling
would help you
to use the data to
design new therapies,
or even, in a synthetic
biology context,
to re-engineer organisms
for new purposes?
So microbes to
generate-- to produce
fuel, for example, or
other useful products.
What can we currently measure?
What does each type of
data mean individually?
What are the strengths
and weaknesses
of each of the types of
high throughput approaches
that we have?
And how do we integrate all
the data we have on a system
to understand the
functioning of that system?
So these are some of
the questions that
motivate the latter topics
on regulatory networks.
OK.
So let's now zoom in
and look more closely
at the course syllabus.
I've just broken
it into two halves,
just so it's more readable.
So today we're going over,
obviously, course mechanics
mostly.
On Thursday, we'll cover
both some DNA sequencing
technologies and we'll talk
about local alignment on BLAST.
More on that in a bit.
The 6.8047 recitation--
6.874, thank you-- recitation
will be on Friday.
The other recitations
will start next week.
And then, as you can see, we'll
move through the other topics.
So each of the
instructors is going
to briefly review their topic.
So I won't go through
all the titles here.
But please note,
on the left side
here, that their assignment
due dates are marked.
OK?
And they're all due at
noon on the indicated day.
And so some of these
are problem sets.
So for example,
problem set 1 will
be due on Thursday,
February 20 at noon.
And some of the
other assignments
relate to the project component
of the course, which we're
going to talk more
about in a moment.
In particular,
we're going to ask
you to submit a brief
statement of your background
and your research interests
related to forming teams.
So the projects are
going to be done
in teams of one
to five students.
And in order to
facilitate especially
cross disciplinary
teams-- we'd love
if you interact
with, maybe, students
in a different grad
program, or whatever--
you'll post your background.
You know, I'm a
first year BE student
and I have a background
in Perl programming,
but never done Python, or
whatever-- something like that.
And then, I'm interested
in doing systems biology
modeling in microbial systems,
or something like that.
And then you can match
up your interests
with others and form teams.
And then you'll come up
with your own project ideas
so that the team
and initial idea
will be due here, February 25th.
Then you'll need to do
some aims and so forth.
So the project components
here, these are only for those
taking the grad
version of the course.
We'll make that clear later.
OK.
So after the first
three topics here,
taught by myself and David,
there will be an exam.
More on that later.
And then there will be three
more topics, mostly taught
by Ernest.
And notice there are additional
assignments here related
to the project-- so,
to research strategy--
and the final written report,
additional problems sets.
We'll have a guest
lecturer here.
This will be Ron Weiss.
Then, there will
be the second exam.
Exams are non-cumulative,
so the second exam
will just cover these three
topics here predominantly.
And then there will be
another guest lecturer.
This would be
George Church here.
And then notice,
here, presentation.
So those who are doing
the project component,
those teams will be given--
assigned a time to present,
to the class, the results
of their research.
And you'll be graded--
the presentation will
be part of the overall
project grade assigned
by the instructors.
But you'll also-- we'll
also ask all the students
in the class to send comments
on the presentations.
So you may find that you
get helpful suggestions
about interpreting your data
from other people and so forth.
So that'll be a
required component
of the course for all students,
to attend the presentations
and comment on them.
And we hope that
will be a lot of fun.
OK.
So is this the
right course for me?
So I just wanted to
let you know you're
fortunate to have a rich
selection of courses
in computational systems,
synthetic biology here at MIT.
I've listed many of them.
Probably not all,
but the ones that I'm
aware of that are
available on-campus.
757 is really only for
biology grad students.
But the other courses listed
here are generally open.
Some are more geared for
graduate students, some more
undergrads.
Some are more specialized.
So for example, Jeff Gore's
systems biology course,
it's more focused
on systems biology
whereas our course covers both
computational and systems.
So keep that in mind.
Make sure you're
in the right place,
that this is what you want.
OK.
A few notes on the textbook--
so there is a textbook.
It's not required.
It's called Understanding
Bioinformatics
by Zvelebil and Baum.
It's quite good
on certain topics.
But it really only covers
about, maybe, a third of what
we cover in the course.
So there is good content
on local alignment,
global alignment,
scoring matrices--
the topics of the
next couple lectures.
And I'll point you
to those chapters.
But it's very
important to emphasize
that the content of
the course is really
what happens in lecture,
and on the homeworks,
and to some extent, what
happens in recitation.
And the textbook is just there
as a backup, if you will,
or for those who
would like to get more
background on the
topic or want to read
a different description
of that topic.
So you decide whether you
want to purchase the textbook
or not.
It's available at the
Coop or through Amazon.
Shop around.
You can find it.
It's paperback.
Pretty good general reference
on a variety of topics,
but it doesn't really have
much on systems biology.
All right.
Another important reference
that was developed specifically
for this course a few years
ago is the probability
and statistics primer.
So you'll notice that
some of the homeworks,
particularly in the earlier
parts of the course,
will have significant
probability and statistics.
And we assume that you have
some background in this area.
Many of you do.
If you don't, you'll
need to pick that up.
And this primer was written
to provide those topics,
in probability especially,
that are foundational
and most relevant to
computational biology.
So for example, there
are some concepts
like p-value, probability
density function, probability
mass function, cumulative
distribution function,
and then, common distributions,
exponential distribution,
Poisson distribution,
extreme value distribution.
If those are mostly sounding
familiar to you, that's good.
If they're familiar, but
you couldn't-- you really
don't-- you get binomial and
Poisson confused or something,
then, definitely, you want
to consult this primer.
So I think, looking at the
lectures and the homeworks,
it should probably
become pretty clear
which aspects are
going to be relevant.
And I'll try to point
those out when possible.
And you can also
consult your TAs
if you're having trouble with
the probability and statistics
content.
So we are going to
focus, here, on, really,
the computational biology,
bioinformatics content.
And we might briefly review
a concept from probability,
like, maybe, conditional
probability when
we talk about Markov chains.
But we're not going to
spend a lot of time.
So if that's the
first time you've
seen conditional probability,
you might be a little bit lost.
So you'd be better off
reading about it in advance.
OK?
Questions?
No questions?
All right.
Maybe it's that the video
is intimidating people.
OK.
All right.
The TAs know a lot about
probability and statistics
and will be able to help you.
OK.
So homework-- so I
apologize, the font
is a little bit small here.
So I'll try to state it clearly.
So there are going
to be five problem
sets that are roughly
one per topic.
Except you'll see p set two
covers topics two and three.
So it might be a
little bit longer.
The way we handle students who
have to travel-- so many of you
might be seniors.
You might be interviewing
for graduate schools.
Or you might have other
conflicts with the course.
So rather than
doing that on a case
by case basis, which, we've
found, gets very complicated
and is not necessarily fair,
the way we've set it up
is that the total number of
points available on the five
homeworks is 120.
OK?
But the maximum score
that you can get is 100.
So if you, for example,
were to get 90% on all five
of the homeworks,
that would be 90%
of 120, which would
be 108 points.
You would get the
full 100-- you'd
get 100% on your homework.
That would be a perfect
score on the homework.
OK?
But because of that-- because
there's more points available
than you need-- we don't
allow you to drop homeworks,
or to do an alternate
assignment, or something
like that.
So the way it works
is you can basically
miss-- as long as
you do well on, say,
four of the homeworks--
you could actually
miss one without
much of a penalty.
For example, if each of the
homeworks were worth 24 points
and you got a perfect
score on four of them,
that would be 96 points.
You would have an almost
perfect score on your homework
and you could miss
that fifth homework.
Now of course, we
don't encourage
you to skip that homework.
We think the homeworks are
useful and are a good way
to solidify the information
you've gotten from lecture,
and reading, and so forth.
So It's good to do them.
And doing the homeworks
will help you and perhaps
prepare you for the exams.
But that's the way we
handle the homework policy.
Now I should also mention that
not all the homeworks will
be the same number of points.
We'll apportion the
points in proportion
to the difficulty and length
of the homework assignment.
So for example, the
first homework assignment
is a little bit easier
than the others.
So it's going to have
somewhat fewer points.
So late assignments--
so all the homeworks
are due at noon on
the indicated day.
And if it's within
24 hours after that,
you'll be eligible
for 50% credit.
And beyond that, you don't
get any points, in part
because the TAs will be posting
the answers to the homeworks.
OK?
And we want to be able to post
them promptly so that you'll
get the answers while
those problems are
fresh in your mind.
Questions about homeworks?
OK.
Good.
So collaboration
on problem sets--
so we want you to
do the problem sets.
You can do them independently.
You can work with a friend
on them, or even in a group,
discuss them together.
But write up your
solutions independently.
You don't learn
anything by copying
someone else's solution.
And if the TAs see duplicate
or near identical solutions,
both of those
homeworks will get a 0.
OK?
And this occasionally happens.
We don't want this
to happen to you.
So just avoid that.
So discuss together, but write
up your solutions separately.
Similarly, with
programming, if you
have a friend who's a more
experienced programmer
than you are, by
all means, ask them
for advice, general things, how
should I structure my program,
do you know of a function
that generates a loop,
or whatever it is that you need.
But don't share code
with anyone else.
OK?
That would be a no-no.
So write up your
code independently.
And again, the graders will
be looking for identical code.
And that will be thrown out.
And so we don't want
to have any misconduct
of that type occurring.
All right.
So recitations-- there are
three recitation sessions
offered each week,
Wednesday at 4:00 by Peter,
Thursday at 4:00 by Colette,
Friday at 4:00 by Tahin.
And that is a special
recitation that's
required for the 6.874
students-- David?
Yes-- and has
additional AI content.
So anyone is welcome to
go to that recitation.
But those who are
taking 6.874 must go.
For students registered for the
other versions of the course,
going to recitation is optional
but strongly recommended.
Because the TAs will go over
material from the lectures,
material that's helpful
for the homeworks
or for studying for exams--
in the first weeks, Python,
probability as well.
So go to the
recitations, particularly
if you're having
trouble in the course.
So Tahin's recitation
starts this week.
And Peter and Colette's
will start next week.
Question.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Are they covering
the same material, Peter
and Colette?
PROFESSOR: Peter and Colette
will cover similar material
and Tahin will cover
different material.
Python instruction-- so
the first problem set,
which will be
posted this evening,
doesn't have any
programming on it.
But if you don't
have programming,
you need to start
learning it very soon.
And so there will be a
significant programming problem
on p set two.
And we'll be posting that
problem soon-- this week,
some time.
And you'll want to
look at that and gauge,
how much Python
do I need to learn
to at least do that problem.
So what is this
project component
that we've been hearing about?
So here's a more
concrete description.
So again, this is only
for the graduate versions
of the course.
So students will--
basically, we've
structured it so you
work incrementally
toward the final
research project
and so that we can offer
feedback and help along the way
if needed.
So the first assignment
will be next week.
I think it's on Tuesday.
I'll have more instructions
on Thursday's lecture.
But all the students
registered for the grad version
will submit their
background and interests
for posting on the
course website.
And then you can
look at those and try
to find other students who
have, ideally, similar interests
but perhaps somewhat
different backgrounds.
It's particularly
helpful to have
a strong biologist on the team.
And perhaps, a strong
programmer would help as well.
So then, you will
choose your teams
and submit a project title
and one-paragraph summary,
the basic idea of your project.
Now we are not providing a
menu of research projects.
It's your choice--
whatever you want
to do, as long as it's related
to computational and systems
biology.
So it could be analysis of
some publicly available data.
Could be analysis of
some data that you
got during your rotation.
Or for those of you who are
already in labs that you're
actually working
on, it's totally
fine and encouraged that the
project be something that's
related to your main PhD work
if you've started on that.
And it could also be more in
the modeling, some modeling
with MATLAB or something, if
you're familiar with that.
But, a variety of possibilities.
We'll have more
information on this later.
But we want you to form teams.
The teams can work independently
or with up to four friends
in teams of five.
And if people want
to have a giant team
to do some really
challenging project,
then you can come
and discuss with us.
And we'll see if
that would work.
So then there's
the initial title
and one-paragraph summary.
We'll give you a little
feedback on that.
And then you'll submit an
actual specific aims document--
so with actual,
NIH-style, specific aims--
the goal is to understand
whether this organism has
operons or not, or some actual
scientific question-- and a bit
about how you will
undertake that.
And then you'll submit a longer
two-page research strategy,
which will include,
specifically,
we will use these data.
We will use this software,
these statistical
approaches-- that sort of thing.
And then, toward the end of
the semester, a final written
report will be due
that'll be five pages.
You'll work on it
together, but it'll
need to be clear who did what.
You'll need an author
contribution statement.
So and so did this analysis.
So and so wrote this
section-- that sort of thing.
And then, as I
mentioned before, there
will be oral presentations,
by each team,
on the last two course sessions.
OK?
Questions about the projects?
There's more information on the
course info document online.
OK?
Good.
Yes, so for those taking 6.874,
in addition to the project,
there will also be
additional AI problems
on both the p
sets-- and the exam?
David?
Yes.
OK.
And they're optional for others.
All right.
Good.
OK.
So how are we going
to do the exam?
So as I mentioned, there's
two 80-minute exams.
They're non-cumulative.
So the first exam
covers, basically,
the first three topics.
The second exam is on
the last three topics.
They're 80 minutes.
They're during
normal class time.
There's no final exam.
The grading-- so for those
taking the undergrad version,
the homeworks will count 36%
out of the maximum 100 points.
And the exams will count 62%.
And then, this
peer review, where
there's two days
where you go, and you
listen to presentations,
and you submit
comments online counts 2%.
For the graduate
Bio BE HST versions,
it's 30% homeworks, 48% exams,
20% project, 2% peer review.
For the EECS version, 6.874,
25% homework, 48% exams, 20%
project, and then, 5% for
these extra AI related
problems, and 2% peer review.
And those should add up to 100.
And then, in addition, we
will reward 1% extra credit
for outstanding
class participation--
so questions,
comments during class.
OK.
All right.
So a few announcements
about topic one.
And then, each of us will review
the topics that are coming up.
So p set one will
be posted tonight.
It's due February 20th, at noon.
It involves basic microbiology,
probability, and statistics.
It'll give you some
experience with BLAST
and some of the
statistics associated.
P set two will be
posted later this week.
So you don't need to, obviously,
start on p set two yet.
It's not due for several weeks.
But definitely, look at
the programming problem
to give you an idea
of what's involved
and what to focus on when
you're reviewing your Python.
Mentioned the
probability/stats primer.
Sequencing technology--
so for Thursday's lecture,
it will be very helpful if you
read the review, by Metzger,
on next gen sequencing
technologies.
It's pretty well written.
Covers Illumina,
454, PACBIO, and
a few other interesting
sequence technologies.
Other background
reading-- so we'll
be talking about local
alignment, global alignment,
statistics, and similarly
matrices for the next two
lectures.
And chapters four and
five of the textbook
provide a pretty good
background on these topics.
I encourage you to take a look.
OK.
So I'm just going to
briefly review my lectures.
And then we'll have David
and Ernest do the same.
So sequencing
technologies will be
the beginning of lecture two.
And then we'll talk about
local ungapped sequence
alignment-- in
particular, BLAST.
So BLAST is something
like the Google search
engine of bioinformatics,
if you will.
It's one of the most
widely used tools.
And it's important to understand
something about how it works,
and in particular,
how to evaluate
the significance of BLAST
hits, which are described
by this extreme value
distribution here.
And then, lecture three, we'll
talk about global alignment
and introducing gaps
into sequence alignments.
We'll talk about some
dynamic programming
algorithms-- Needleman-Wunsch,
Smith-Waterman.
And in lecture four,
we'll talk about
comparative genomic analysis
of gene regulation--
so using sequence similarity
across genomes two infer
location of regulatory elements
such as microRNA target
sites, other things like that.
All right.
So I think this is now-- oh
sorry, a few more lectures.
Then, in the next unit,
modeling biological function,
I'll talk about the
problem of motif finding--
so searching a set of sequences
for a common subsequence,
or similar subsequences,
that possess
a particular
biological function,
like binding to a protein.
It's often a complex
search space.
We'll talk about
the Gibbs sampling
algorithm and some alternatives.
And then, in lecture
10, I'll talk
about Markov and hidden
Markov models, which
have been called the Legos
of bioinformatics, which
can be used to model a
variety of linear sequence
labeling problems.
And then, in the last
lecture of that unit,
I'll talk a little
bit about protein--
I'm sorry, about RNA--
secondary structure--
so the base pairing of
RNAs-- predicting it
from thermodynamic
tools, as well as
comparative genomic approaches.
And you'll learn
about the mfold tool
and how you can use
a diagram like that
to infer that this RNA may have
different possible structures
that I can fold into,
like those shown.
All right.
So I'm going to pass
it off to David here.
PROFESSOR: Thanks
very much, Chris.
All Right.
So I'm David Gifford.
And I'm delighted to be here.
It's really a
wonderfully exciting time
in computational biology.
And one of the reasons
it's so exciting
is shown on this slide, which
is the production of DNA base
sequence per
instrument over time.
And as you can see, it's
just amazingly more efficient
as time goes forward.
And if you think about the
reciprocal of this curve,
the cost per base is basically
becoming extraordinarily low.
And this kind of
instrument allows
us to produce
hundreds of millions
of sequence reads for
a single experiment.
And thus do we not only need
new computational methods
to handle this kind
of a big data problem,
but we need
computational methods
to represent the results
in computational models.
And so we have multiple
challenges computationally.
Because modern biology
really can't be done
outside of a
computational framework.
And to summarise the
way people have adapted
these high throughput DNA
sequencing instruments,
I built this small
figure for you.
And you can see that--
Professor Burge will
be talking about DNA
sequencing next time.
And obviously, you
can use DNA sequencing
to sequence your own
genomes, or the genomes
of your favorite pet,
or whatever you like.
And so we'll talk about,
in lecture six, how
to actually do
genome sequencing.
And one of the challenges
in doing genome sequencing
is how to actually find
what you have sequenced.
And we'll be talking about how
to map sequence reads as well.
Another way to
use DNA sequencing
is to take the RNA species
present in a single cell,
or in a population of
cells, and convert them
into DNA using
reverse transcriptase.
Then we can sequence the DNA
and understand the RNA component
of the cell, which,
of course, either
can be used as messenger
RNA to code for protein,
or for structural RNAs, or
for non-coding RNAs that
have other kinds of functions
associated with chromatin.
In lecture seven,
we'll be talking
about protein/DNA interactions,
which Professor Burge already
mentioned-- the idea
that we can actually
locate all the regulatory
factors associated
with the genome using a single
high throughput experiment.
We do this by isolating the
proteins and their associated
DNA fragments and
sequencing the DNA fragments
using this DNA
sequencing technology.
So briefly, the first
thing that we'll
look at in lecture five is,
given a reference genome
sequence and a basket
of DNA sequence reads,
how do we build
an efficient index
so that we can either
map or align those
reads back to the
reference genome.
That's a very important
and fundamental problem.
Because if I give you a
basket of 200 million reads,
we need to build its
alignment very, very rapidly,
and quickly, and
accurately, especially
in the context of
repetitive elements.
Because a genome obviously
has many repeats in it.
We need to consider how
our indexing and searching
algorithms are going to handle
those sorts of elements.
In the next lecture,
we'll talk about how
to actually sequence a
genome and assemble it.
So the fundamental way that
we approach genome sequencing
given today's
sequencing instruments
is that we take intact
chromosomes at the top, which,
of course, are hundreds
of millions of bases long,
and we shatter them into pieces.
And then we sequence
size selected pieces
in a sequencing instrument.
And then we need to put the
jigsaw puzzle back together
with a computational assembler.
So we'll be talking about
assembly algorithms, how
they work, and furthermore,
how resolve ambiguities
as we put that puzzle
together, which often arise
in the context of
repetitive sequence.
And in the next lecture,
in lecture seven,
we'll be looking at how to
actually take those little DNA
molecules that are
associated with proteins
and analyze them to figure out
where particular proteins are
bound to the genome and how they
might regulate target genes.
Here we see two
different occurrences
of OCT4 binding events
binding proximally
to the SOX2 gene, which
they are regulating.
So that's the beginning of our
analysis of DNA sequencing.
And then we'll look at RNA
sequencing-- once again,
with going through
a DNA intermediate--
and ask the question,
how can we look
at the expression
of particular genes
by mapping RNA sequence
reads back onto the genome.
And there are two fundamental
questions we can address here,
which is, what is the level
of expression of a given gene,
and secondarily, what
isoforms are being expressed.
The second sets of reads,
you see up on the screen,
are split reads that
cross splice junctions.
And so by looking at how
reads align to the genome,
we can figure out which
particular axons are included
or excluded from a
particular transcript.
So that's the beginning of
the high throughput biology
genomic analysis module.
And I'll be returning to
talk, later in the term,
about computational genetics,
which, really, is a way
to summarize everything
we're learning
in the course into
an applicable way
to ask fundamental questions
about genome function, which
Professor Burge
talked about earlier.
Now we all have about 3
billion bases in our genomes.
And as you know, you
differ from the individual
sitting next to you in about
one in every 1,000 base pairs,
on average.
And so one question
is, how do we actually
interpret these differences
between genomes.
And how can we build
accurate computational models
that allow us to infer
function from genome sequence?
And that's a pretty
big challenge.
So we'll start by
asking questions about,
what parts of the
genome are active
and how could we annotate them.
So we can use, once again,
different kinds of sequencing
based assays to identify the
regions of the genome that
are active in any
given cellular state.
And furthermore, if we
look at different cells,
we can tell which
parts of the genome
are differentially active.
Here you can see
the active chromatin
during the
differentiation of an ESL
into a terminal type over
a 50 kilobase window.
And the regions of the genome
that are shaded in yellow
represent regions that
are differentially active.
And so, using this kind of
DNA seq. data and other data,
we can automatically
annotate the genome
with where the
regulatory elements are
and begin to understand what the
regulatory code of the genome
is.
So once we understand what
parts of the genome are active,
we can ask questions
about, how do they
contribute to some
overall phenotype.
And our next
lecture, lecture 19,
we'll be looking
at how we can build
a model of a
quantitative trait based
upon multiple loci and the
particular alleles that
are present at that loci.
So here you see an
example of a bunch
of different
quantitative trait loci
that are contributing to
the growth rate of yeast
in a given condition.
So part of our exploration
during this term
will be to develop
computational methods
to automatically identify
regions of the genome that
control such traits and to
assign them significance.
And finally, we'd like to
put all this together and ask
a very fundamental
question, which
is, how do we assign
variations in the human genome
to differential risk
for human disease.
And associated questions
are, how could we
assign those variants to what
best therapy would be applied
to the disease--
what therapeutics
might be used, for example.
And here we have
a bunch of results
from genome wide
association studies,
starting at the top
with bipolar disorder.
And at the bottom
is type 2 diabetes.
And looking along
the chromosomes,
we're asking which
locations along the genome
have variants that
are highly associated
with these particular diseases
in these so-called Manhattan
plots.
Because the things that
stick up look like buildings.
And so these sorts of studies
are yielding very interesting
insights into variants that are
associated with human disease.
And the next step, of
course, is to figure out
how to actually prove that
these variants are causal,
and also, to look
at mechanisms where
we might be able to address
what kinds of therapeutics
might be applied to deal
with these diseases.
So those are my two units.
Once again, high throughput
genomic analysis,
and secondarily,
computational genetics.
And finally, if you have
any questions about 6.874,
I'll be here after lecture.
Feel free to ask me.
Ernest.
PROFESSOR: Thank
you very much, Dave.
All right.
So in the preceding
lectures, you'll
have heard a lot about
the amazing things
we can learn from
nucleic acid sequencing.
And what we're going to do in
the latter part of the course
is look at other
modalities in the cell.
Obviously, there's
a lot that goes
on inside of cells
that's not taking place
at the level of DNA/RNA.
And so we're going to start
to look at proteins, protein
interactions, and ultimately,
protein interaction networks.
So we'll start with
the small scale,
looking at intermolecular
interactions
of the biophysics-- the
fundamental biophysics
of a protein structure.
Then we'll start to look at
protein-protein interactions.
And as I said, the final
level will be networks.
There's been an amazing
advance in our ability
to predict protein structure.
So it's always been the dream
of computational biology
to be able to go from
the sequence of a gene
to the structure of the
corresponding protein.
And ever since Anfinsen,
we know that, at least,
that should be theoretically
possible for a lot of proteins.
But it's been computationally
virtually intractable
until quite recently.
And a number of
different approaches
have allowed us to
predict protein structure.
So this slide
shows, for example--
I don't know which one's
which-- but in blue, perhaps,
prediction, and in red, the
true structure, or the other way
around.
But you can see, it
doesn't matter very much.
We're getting extremely accurate
predictions of small protein
structure.
There are a variety
of approaches here
that live on a spectrum.
On the one hand, there's
the computational approach
that tries to make special
purpose hardware to carry out
the calculations for
protein structure.
And that's been
wildly successful.
On the other end of
the extreme, there's
been the crowd sourcing
approach to have gamers
try to predict
protein structure.
And that turns out
to be successful.
And there's a lot of interesting
computational approaches
in the middle as well.
So we'll explore some of
these different strategies.
Then, the ability to go from
just seeing a single protein
structure, how these
proteins interact.
So now there are
pretty good algorithms
predicting protein-protein
interactions as well.
And that allows us, then,
to figure out not only
how these proteins
function individually,
but how they begin to
function as a network.
Now one of the things
that we've already--
going to be touched on in
the early parts of the course
are protein-DNA interactions
through sequencing approaches.
We want to now look at
them at a regulatory level.
And could you reconstruct
the regulation of a genome
by predicting the protein-DNA?
And there's been a
lot of work here.
We talked earlier
about Eric Davidson's
pioneering approaches, a lot
of interesting computational
approaches as well, that go from
the relatively simple models we
saw on those earlier slides to
these very complicated networks
that you see here.
We'll look at what
these networks actually
tell us, how much information
is really encoded in them.
They are certainly
pretty, whatever they are.
We'll look at other kinds
of interactions networks.
We'll look at genetic
interaction networks as well,
and perhaps, some other kinds.
And finally, we'll look
at computable models.
And what do we mean by that?
We mean model that
make some kind of very
specific prediction,
whether it's
a Boolean prediction-- this gene
will be on or off-- or perhaps,
an even more
quantitative prediction.
So we'll look at
logic based modeling,
and probably, Bayesian
networks as well.
So that's been a very
whirlwind tour of the course.
Just to go back
to the mechanics,
make sure you're signed
up for the right course.
The undergraduate
versions of the course
do not have a project.
And they certainly do not have
the artificial intelligence
problems.
Then, there are the graduate
versions that have the project,
but do not have the AI,
and finally, the 6.874,
which has both.
So please be sure you're
in the right class
so you get credit for
the right assignments.
And finally, if you've got
any questions about the course
mechanics, we have
a few minutes.
We can talk about it here,
in front of everybody.
And then, we'll all be available
after class, a little bit,
to answer questions.
So please, any questions?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Can
undergrads do a project?
PROFESSOR: Can
Well, they can sign up for the
graduate version, absolutely.
Other questions?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I actually can't
make either of those sessions.
PROFESSOR: Well, send an
email to the staff list
and we'll see what we can do.
Other questions?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: 6.877
doesn't exist anymore--
Computational Evolutionary
Biology, the class.
PROFESSOR: Oh, the thing we
listed as alternative classes?
Sorry.
PROFESSOR: We'll fix that.
AUDIENCE: Really?
I would be so happy.
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: We'll delete
it from our slides, yes.
We are powerful, but
not that powerful.
Other questions,
comments, critiques?
Yes, in the back.
AUDIENCE: Are each of the
exams equally weighted?
PROFESSOR: Are each of the
Yes, they are.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: If we're in 6.874,
we have the additional AI
problems.
Does that mean that we have
more questions on the exam,
but just as much
time to do them?
PROFESSOR: The question
was, if you're in 6.874
and you have the additional
AI questions on the exam,
does that mean you
have more questions,
but the same amount of time.
And I believe the
answer to that is yes.
PROFESSOR: We may
revisit that question.
PROFESSOR: We will revisit
that question at a later date.
But course six students
are just so much smarter
than everyone else, right?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Can we switch between
different versions of the class
by the add deadline?
PROFESSOR: I'm sorry,
could you say that again?
AUDIENCE: Can we switch
between versions of the class
by the add deadline?
PROFESSOR: Can you switch
between different versions
of class by the
add/drop deadline?
In principle, yes.
But if you haven't
done the work for that,
then you will be in trouble.
And there may not be
a smooth mechanism
for making up missed
work that late.
Because the add/drop
deadline is rather late.
So I'd encourage you,
if you're considering
doing the more intensive
version or not,
sign up for the more
intensive version.
You can always drop back.
Once we form groups
though, for the projects,
then, obviously,
there's an aspect
of letting down your teammates.
So think carefully, now, about
which one you want to join.
It'll be hard to
switch between them.
But we'll do whatever
the registrar requires
us to do in terms
of allowing it.
Other questions?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: If the course sites,
can we undergrads access the AI
problems just for
fun, to look at them?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
If the course sites
remain separate,
will undergrads be able
to access the AI problems?
The answer is yes.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Should
students in 6.874
attend both presentations?
PROFESSOR: Should
students in 6.874
attend both presentations?
Not necessary.
You're welcome to
both if you want.
But the course six recitation
should be sufficient.
Other questions?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So what's covered
in the normal recitations?
PROFESSOR: What's covered
It'll be reinforcing material
that's in the lectures.
So the goal is not introduce any
new material in the course 20,
course seven recitations.
Just to clarify, not to
introduce any new material.
Other questions?
OK.
Great.
And we'll hang
around a little bit
to answer any remaining
questions when they come up.